hey ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
very special episode of metaphysical
milkshake I know we've been gone for a
while I know you've been missing us I've
been uh traveling around the world
everywhere I go people talk about how
they miss the podcast and you know as
you know we took a little break to kind
of relax a little bit but suddenly I was
given this incredible opportunity uh
someone reached out to me giving me the
chance to interview uh the Creator
should we say Prophet uh Messianic
figure I'm not exactly sure yet of a of
a brand new religion uh this religion
that is called I want to say soul boom
anyway uh you know as those of you who
know me know that I have written a lot
about uh religions in the past I've I've
written about Jesus and Muhammad and
Moses and you know some of the greatest
uh religious thinkers creators of
religions but rarely do I get the
opportunity to actually interview
someone who has just founded his new
religion and I think we're going to be
able to get him on I believe he's he's
in an ashram under a Bodhi Tree
somewhere in the middle of a of a South
Asian jungle sir are you there sir are
you there
oh
rain hey Reza what are you what are you
doing man yeah I'm not uh I'm not under
a boaty tree and I'm not in uh southeast
Asia wait I'm in uh Suburban Los Angeles
this is you
you're the you're the Creator slash
Prophet slash Messianic figure that I've
been so excited to talk to I'm sorry you
didn't know that no one told you no I I
don't I don't really read my emails I
just kind of skim the subject line and
it said something about Soul boom what
it what so what that's a book or
something I know three words in Hebrew
foreign
especially in certain parts of Los
Angeles rain Wilson so let me get this
straight you're you're starting your own
religion am I am I getting that right
here
oh look at that Soul boom yeah I I am
Reza so here's the deal folks here's the
deal thank you for that scintillating
introduction Reza that was that was
great you know I've been practicing my
acting skills while we've been on Hiatus
clearly you quit uh you quit social
media and you've uh you've been honing
your acting skills it was some great
impact thank you very much thank you
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical Milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of Life along
the way
[Music]
so my new book is just an outsole boom
as you know that's what we're here to
talk about folks that's right sorry for
the long Hiatus from metaphysical
milkshake
but I think what you're talking about I
think what you're referring to is the
chapter called hey kids let's build a
new religion
in which I start the soul Boom the
religion shall we get right down to it
listen listen uh first of all uh someone
who's known you for a long time I can't
believe that it's taken you this long to
become a cult leader number one right
I've seen the way people respond to you
uh number two I've actually read this
book and I thoroughly enjoyed it my
friend thank you it's a very funny very
personal uh deep meditation on the the
spiritual crisis uh the rot at the
center of the The Human Condition
humanity and and remarkably you've got
an answer for all of it so let's start
let's start with the same question if
you don't mind uh with which you start
the book which is this why the hell is
the actor who played Dwight on the
office writing a book on spirituality
well excellent question one that I pose
myself as you mentioned
there's a number of different reasons
Reza I mean for those uh metaphysical
milkshake listeners out there who might
be uh familiar with my life story I grew
up as a member of the Baha'i faith and
one of the tenets of the Baha'i faith
and Reza it's tenet not tenants it is
people mispronounce the word tenet
all the time it drives me batshit crazy
tenants are what live in an apartment
building tenets with no end
well no secondhand
are are uh belief values are are
essential beliefs so tell me all about
the people living in the apartment
complex of Baha'i so one of the central
tenants
in my apartment building is a Baha'i and
their Central tenet
is now Baha'is believe in all the
world's religions so we believe in the
essential Divinity it's called a
Universalist religion that's the the a
Universalist kind of take on uh that the
Buddha that Krishna Abraham Moses Jesus
zoroaster to go way way back all of
these are from the same God they are
from the same Divine source and so as
Baha'is we read the Bible in the Quran
and we read the bhagavad-gita and the
dhamapatas of the Buddha and we study
all of these holy religions so one
message many Messengers uh exactly one
and uh
as uh so as a Baha'i I'm very interest
growing up a Baha'i we had all of these
books on our shelves we had Egyptian
mysticism and and Sufi books and seek
books and all kinds of like
autobiography of a of a yogi on on the
shelf and
um these kind of like probing life's big
questions were a big part of growing up
in a Baha'i household so
this is a continuing conversation that
I've been having it started with my
family and then went to my faith
community and then my friends and then
with you on this podcast with my friends
over at Seoul pancake and onwards and
onwards and now on the pages of Soul
boom which is you know
how do we use spirituality how does
spirituality affect our lives can we put
it can we put these Central tenets these
this wisdom uh this Faith wisdom from
eons uh of spiritual teachers can we put
it into practice to make our personal
lives better but also Reza can we put it
into practice to make Society better
so that's part one that's part one let
me go to part two part two is I was
really up in my 20s
you write a lot about that yeah so I was
unhappy I suffered from mental health
issues I had crippling anxiety attacks I
had depression I had addiction issues
loneliness and alienation chronic
dissatisfaction and
as I was kind of like hitting bottom for
I didn't really like literally hit
bottom with drugs and alcohol or
anything like that but but
metaphorically hitting bottom I really
went on a quest to find
um
God and find the truth and you know try
and decide is there you know perhaps I
threw the spiritual baby out with the
religious bath water when I rejected the
Baha'i faith and anything and everything
to do with religion in my 20s and maybe
there are some some answers to be found
there and that's what kind of rebooted
my journey
um and I've spoken about that story
before but you put those things together
and then it's coveted and then all of a
sudden I know I'm going to be unemployed
for many many months maybe many years
which I was and I had the opportunity to
finally kind of write a book that was
kind of a as I write in the book it's a
throwing a bunch of spiritual spaghetti
at the wall and seeing what sticks and
that's what I did yeah
it's a memoir it's a it's a Manifesto
It's a history lesson there's a lot
there's a lot of really wonderful stuff
in here but I feel like before we delve
too deeply into it let's let's make sure
everybody's on the same page because
this term spirituality I mean everybody
I throw it around you throw it around
you talk about you want to launch a
spiritual Revolution so maybe we should
start really at the beginning and and
just find out what is it exactly do you
mean when you use the word spiritual or
spirituality like what are you talking
about rain well I think I'm really glad
that we're defining our terms because
there's a lot of terms like this there's
you know God is something that people
talk about and are can be completely on
different pages about
um the soul
um you know the list goes on and on but
spirituality is an important one because
to a lot of people it means
seances and ghosts because some people
you know it is a it is a feeling that
you get in your chest when you're at a
yoga class or meditating or have a
certain incense or crystals going not
that there's anything wrong with any of
those things
um to some folks it's church on Sunday
that spirituality is is you know what
happens when you go to your to your
church or your mosque or your synagogue
um for me
we are um integrated however uh
dualistic forms so we have a body and a
spirit and they're not kind of separate
like salt and pepper shakers they're
integrated we are having a spiritual
experience inside of a human body but
that spiritual experience is is what I'm
talking about anything that is non the
non-material part of ourselves so what
is that it's our divine virtues
it's our kindness our love our
compassion our honesty our humility it's
um that part of ourselves that when our
physical body Fades away that continues
on whatever that glorious Journey uh
into the infinite looks like that's what
it means to be spiritual and it is
anything of and concerning the Divine
um and it gets it gets tricky because
when you start talking about this it
starts to sound really dualistic it's
like Mind Body you know Body Soul it's
all it's all one reality they are just
different facets of the same reality and
I think that's it's important to note
that as well and of course your
spiritual journey as you know your fans
and and longtime listeners of
metaphysical milkshake no uh did not
begin with a deep dive into the Bible or
uh the Quran but rather uh two
television shows right Kung Fu and Star
Trek like that's that's where the
foundation of your spiritual journey uh
began uh you've talked a lot about this
before but why don't you just tell us a
little bit about what was it about those
two shows that like launched you on this
path towards uh uh a a like a spiritual
uh knowledge spiritual thirst
we've talked about Star Trek a lot of
the show oh yeah I know you're a you're
a Die Hard Trekker Trekker Trekkie what
do you prefer again well I don't want to
get into semantics
it's Trekker let's define whatever
Trekkie whatever your tracker you know
okay
Will Wheaton told us you don't have to
be a zealot about it just you can love
Star Trek and just leave it at that so
did you just name drop the title if you
happen to have written a book about that
name isn't that weird Trekker no no no
get back to you get back to your answer
okay I'm getting back to my story listen
I think it's very important in term in
defining terms again
to understand that the way that I see it
there are two spiritual paths and I'll
come back to this later on there is a
personal
uh spiritual path that is internal
transformational it's about one's
relationship with one's higher power
becoming a better person walking your
life seeking tranquility and peace and
understanding and meaning in your
personal life so that's one path there
is another spiritual path that we don't
talk about quite as much but when you
pull back and look at the full
Kaleidoscope of History you see that
this also exists and that is the
spiritual maturation of the human race
and its inevitable growth and
Transcendence and these two television
shows my two favorite television shows
of the 70s Star Trek and Kung Fu are
kind of revelatory of these two paths so
kung fu for those who don't know why
Chang Kane
grew up in a Shaolin Monastery in the
1800s he gets kicked out of the
monastery he goes to the old west to
look for his brother he's wandering
around the old west the Wild Wild West
with a bunch of racist Cowboys and he
fights Kung Fu but he's also a Taoist
he's also part Buddhist he has a deep
reservoir of Eastern wisdom that he's
learned and he's coming into contact
with all these angry racist upset people
who are struggling and materialistic and
trying to eke out a living in the old
west and he brings his
peace and his calm and his wisdom and
his ass kicking skills
um on his journey and so I talk about
that as part one this is our personal
spiritual journey we are all Kwai Chang
Kane we are all have our wisdom we all
have our ass kicking skills we're going
down the path of the road
um seeking to become better people to
share our wisdom to serve others and to
seek tranquility and serenity in our
lives in fact uh if I could just there's
this really really fun part of the book
where you do this thing where uh you uh
have this quiz and the quiz is is this
quote uh from some great you know
religious scripture or is it from Kung
Fu the series and uh I gotta say
half of those wrong I'm gonna try and
I'm gonna try and stump you right now
okay
is this Kung Fu or famous religious
quote right
Carpenters bend wood the wise Master
themselves I just gotta be Kung Fu it's
got to be Kung Fu
that's the Buddha damn it all right one
more
humanity is but a single Brotherhood so
make peace with your brethren
um that sounds like something for hola
would have said
Muhammad no
no oh my people my people are rolling
right now they're just like oh Reza how
about this a tranquil heart gives life
to the flesh but Envy makes the bones
rot I feel like just to be on the safe
side I'm gonna say kung fu
the Bible damn it
I'm telling you guys this is a tough
it's a tough little there are more ways
to preserve than to destroy
okay I'm just gonna say Kung Fu because
I I have to it is kung fu it's I had to
put in one combo but it's it's hard to
yeah nobody it's hard to that's deep
listen for uh you know what like a
spaghetti western star in David
carradianas a Chinese man uh there was
some deep deep stuff in that show
absolutely absolutely so tell me okay
then then where does Star Trek fit in
all this so Star Trek of course
at first blush it's all about science
and technology right and you know
Humanity's kind of going boldly going
where no man has gone before in outer
space seeking out new life new
civilizations Etc but the mythology of
Star Trek is back on planet Earth there
has been a devastating War
out of the ashes of that war Humanity
has finally United
and
pooling their resources and their
technological advances Humanity has
solved racism Humanity has solved income
inequality and sexism and militarism
come together in one world government so
anytime you hear people saying ah One
World Government you know as like a
conspiracy you just say Star Trek
it's kind of better right one world
government kind of cool Federation kind
of works
so this is to me
about Humanity's Pro spiritual progress
there are these and I have a chapter
called a plethora of pandemics where I
list the dozens of pandemics that are
afflicting Humanity from racism to
militarism to income inequality
the ones I've mentioned including
climate change the mental health
epidemic for young people materialism
these
yes these uh uh these pandemics
uh
certainly we need uh legislation to help
solve them but underlying them
underpinning these are they are they're
based in a spiritual disease and uh
spiritual wisdom and growth can be
achieved and can be worked for
um
by us people on planet Earth
um seeking to make our world a little
bit more like Star Trek
there is a third pillar
if I may say so uh to please your kind
of spiritual
uh edifice if you will uh besides come
through and Star Trek and it's your dad
you know your dad uh who was Baha'i who
who raised you uh in the Baha'i faith um
who you know had his own issues and
problems he's been very open about that
you write openly about it in the book
and the two of you you know grew apart
and came back together again there's a
sort of really wonderful probably my
favorite story in the book is the story
um that happens after your dad's uh
death where
um you know you have to according to the
Baha'i faith and the rituals involved
there you have to wash the body and you
realize you don't have
a vessel to wash uh your father's body
so there you are like running around the
target
um
trying to uh get a bowl that's nice
enough that you could use to wash your
your father's dead body which is lying
in a in a a basement a few miles away
um can you talk a little bit about the
role that your father played in giving
you this kind of thirst for Spiritual
edification
so besides you know I dedicated the book
to my father I said thank you for
teaching me about the soul because he
really was a great spiritual teacher for
me
um and I was thinking about writing this
book and and was generating some ideas
for it when covet hit
and then devastatingly about six months
into covid my dad died
he had a
uh he died during open heart surgery
as his heart disease was just too uh
pervasive and it was it was brutal and
devastating and heartbreaking I've
spoken about it before on the show
um
but I had
um a spiritual awakening I had uh as
Oprah would say an aha moment
when he was lying on the
bed at the hospital and we had unplugged
him
and his body was just freshly dead
and that was that you know I saw all the
things of my father's body I saw his
his eyebrows with a little tuft of
eyebrow hair I saw the mole on his cheek
I saw the hair on his arms and the way
his hands looked and
and I had an
overwhelming sensation
this is not my father
this is the vessel that carried my
father it couldn't have been more clear
to me
there was no light there was no life
there was just this flesh and the
essence of Robert Wilson ishness was
just
had moved on had gone on
um so
this experience was you know tragic and
yet also inspiring because I find death
to be a really uh important topic and
one that uh we are terrified to engage
with in Western Society right now we
people are oh death is depressing let's
not look at it but there's a lot to
learn from Death it is the it is the
great perspective Giver
um and the great kind of bookend and
uh this idea that we Are Spiritual
Beings and we're moving on uh through
infinite worlds of the Divine and one
way stop along the way is wearing these
meat suits these flesh tuxedos for 80 or
90 years that became very clear and that
was a great motivator for me to write
the book as well yeah
all right so let's get to it
um you know you mentioned already that
yeah there is like a a kind of spiritual
pandemic we've we've had so many
episodes on this show talking about you
know all the different crises that are
inundating Humanity right now in
particularly
um younger people Millennials gen Z
mental health issues
um obviously like this epic epidemic of
loneliness that we we've talked about
um uh We've certainly talked about you
know climate change we've talked about
political instability
um
you know there's a there's a lot that
this younger generation is going through
um that has created this kind of
existential dilemma within this
generation and you argue in this book
that the answer might be a kind of
spiritual Revolution a renewal of of the
spirit but more specifically I mean you
could have just ended it there and it
would have been like a nice full flu
book and people would have said oh
that's so sweet and they would have
bought it and and they would have had
you sign it and then you would have
moved on hopefully they'll still buy it
and have me sign it but yeah they'll
still buy it and and have you sign it
but then you you take this one other
step in this book which you talked about
at the top of the show where you're like
all right it let's make our own
religion
uh first of all
what I mean is that I don't is that even
a thing like can our actors allowed to
make religions is that a is that a thing
first of all and then you know I mean by
definition aren't all religions kind of
by definition there's some good there's
some bad you know like put another one
into the mix I mean what is what is the
incentive to just say we need a brand
new religion yeah
so I got I got three chapters on
religion in this book religion is not
such a popular topic as you know Reza
yeah it does not make people happy no I
have three chapters on religion because
I think it's really important to look at
religion through a slightly different
lens we have such a knee-jerk reaction
against it right generally in
contemporary Society yeah religion is
the cause of all evil in the world if
there were no religion we would all be
happy and prosperous and peaceful and I
take us through a number of different
aspects of religion because I do think
that we have lost something as a society
as a culture by jettisoning religion and
don't get me started I know the ills
caused by religion I know the wars
caused I know uh the scandal in the
Catholic church I know about suicide
bombers flying into skyscrapers believe
me I I understand all that I mean
conversely one could point to all the
atrocities committed by Man by you know
supposedly atheist or secular uh
cultures but putting that aside
what does religion give you why have
there been religions I mean people you
know resin I see things a little bit
differently for me
I see someone like the Buddha
or someone like Jesus or Muhammad as
specially anointed Divine teachers
they're not just a regular guy they're
not like
Martin Luther King or the Dalai Lama or
you know Desmond Tutu they're they're
exceptional human beings that have been
touched by a very special Divine spark
to give a revelation of teachings and
there are some universals in these
teachings that we've kind of thrown away
that are worth taking a look at right
deep compassion service to the poor
Transcendence the idea of life after
death a greater meaning and purpose to
life
um seeking and building Community
especially at the Grassroots these are
some of the elements of
all religions that humanity is
scrambling for it's no surprise to me
that this mental health epidemic has
kind of
exasperated and elevated and
accelerated uh during the decades that
people have been leaving uh the church
and
when when you do happiness studies and
you and you do and you look at the Hard
data people that are involved in
religions are happier they're more
successful
um they have greater resilience they
live longer and they're just happier
that's I'm sorry I'll use secular folk
it's just true just look at the data and
I'm not suggesting everyone should go
become a a Baptist you know that's not
what I'm talking about so and I'm not
suggesting anyone become a member of any
religion the the point is is just to
kind of mix things up and you know probe
some deep you know human questions and
so I wanted to start my own religion I
thought what would that be like what
what if we had Soul Boom the religion
and besides those universals that uh I I
spoke of
um you know what other aspects could be
a part of
um the soul boom religion let's take the
best bits from the existing religions
and put them in a cauldron and come up
with something new so I say no clerics
right we don't need clerics anymore we
want any priests or mullahs or gurus
anymore not like Quakers get that the
Quakers don't get like Quakers
um diversity plus Harmony so the idea
that diversity is a good thing not a bad
thing something to be cherished
something to be relish uh centrality of
the divine feminine used to be in Many
religious Traditions especially in
indigenous religions we've kind of lost
that and we need to bring that back
um the cooperation and essential Harmony
between science and religion they're not
at odds like many people would have you
believe a profound connection to the
Natural World a life of service the
centrality of Justice can be
front and center in this religious
movement it goes on and on but that was
the idea
um and no listener and no Reza I am not
the leader of Soul Boom the religion
it's purely hypothetical but
we don't have a clergy but
you know we could use
a leader
we could use someone with
um a great deal of knowledge about the
world's religions we could use someone
uh
renowned for their uh esoteric knowledge
we could use someone
Brown I I think I may know someone
Rami Malek
or me me yes
I will listen in all seriousness I will
gladly be your god oh wow okay
you went a little too far too fast no
listen lust lust our our listeners uh
think that this is just some you know
skiing for you to not pay taxes anymore
you take this very seriously like you
you've actually laid this out in very
clear terms you talk about the 10
fundamentals of this religion you've
mentioned them belief in a higher power
and look at whatever you you call it God
you call it you know thingy whatever you
want to call it God's just a word we've
talked about this maybe Maya the great
spirit the great spirit whatever uh
belief in life after death that's vital
to your to your new uh Soul boom
religion that you know what we are is
eternal you've talked about that that's
that's pretty big the power of prayer
that that's interesting like talk about
that aspect of it you know what is how
does prayer work in in the soul boom
religion
like are you are you is it like you know
are you on your are you saying you know
like dear God help me get the job
that's an option you could say dear God
help me get this parking spot uh find a
parking space
in downtown Manhattan
um
that's certain that's certainly a
possibility God can't do everything but
yeah yeah that might be pushing the
limits
um is there a rock so big that even God
cannot find a parking space in downtown
Manhattan
um
the
I've talked about this before but I find
it so interesting that in the
Evangelical
parts of red State America
uh there's a whole lot of praying going
on
right and it's a lot of personal prayer
Jesus
my aunt Connie's sick can you heal her
foot she's got a hangnail you know it
goes like that Jesus let Alabama win
this game yep yeah yep Roll Tide Jesus
um
and then you've got secular La Blue
State America where there's zero praying
and there's a whole lot of medicine
that's going on that's how we learn it's
like I'm mindful I've got my meditation
bench I've got my practice and my app my
mindfulness apps and
um and it's part of my yoga practice so
you've got one half of the country
talking and one half the country
listening but I think it's really
important that we do both and that I do
believe that
so for lack of a better word we're just
going to use the word god
and I do have a chapter in the book
called The Notorious God but the that
this all-powerful uh creative uh force
that
um is in in and Among Us and inside of
us and outside of us and Beyond time and
space is uh unknowable and all-powerful
that we can be in a dialogue with this
force that we can ask for help
um Annie Lamont has a great book called
help thanks wow and she describes the
three types of prayers
there's help you know help me out thanks
oh this is so wonderful thank you God
and wow which is oh my gosh this is just
so beautiful I can't stand it so we can
help think wow uh ourselves into prayer
and we can also and it's crucial that we
also meditate which is listening which
is stillness meditation can be very
helpful in kind of rebooting the mind
and bringing kind of a quietude and
peacefulness and and Solitude and
serenity to one's life and that's
important but I think that I think that
prayer is the most powerful force in the
universe and I've seen it work and
prayer Works which is weird right like I
mean okay maybe prayer doesn't
necessarily make Alabama uh you know
score a touchdown but there's like
greens of scientific data like real hard
science
uh over the last decade or so that has
shown that prayer is actually
strangely mysteriously effective both
for the person praying and for the
people being prayed
for and okay you know you can come up
with a 100 reasons why that is that
doesn't have to do with God but as you
rightly say you know whatever God's just
a word
prayer is just another way of saying
meditation we know how good meditation
is you know for human beings in their
health and uh and like a lot of things
in this uh Soul boom religion which is
becoming more and more appealing to me
by the way as this conversation comes
okay I mean there's nothing like Islam
we have 28 days of like not eating food
or water or having sex like that sucks I
mean this this sounds way better brutal
um but like a lot of the the sort of
foundations that you have
um this one is you know it's very much
like what what you make of it so like
you define what prayer is you have
another Foundation that you call about
Transcendence right which is this just
simply this idea of like you know
surrendering to the the the universe the
the acknowledgment that there is this
sort of great mystery that goes beyond
ourselves and our narrow understanding
of the world you mentioned Community
which is hugely important right that
so much of you know the benefit of
quote-unquote religion is is that sort
of deep sense of belonging that
community that that you have and as long
as you know you don't along with that
create the out Group which seems to
always show up uh it's a it's a hugely
important part you talk about a moral
compass right that you know there's a
sense of morality now that's a tricky
one that's a trick that was a tough one
yeah let's talk about that a little
someone was just talking to me about
that earlier and they were kind of
calling me out on it and they're like
wait a second
so religion provides morality is that
really are you saying that there's like
some
Transcendent Force out there like think
about the Ten Commandments and like
Moses or like atheists are immoral like
that's the flip side of that like right
right right but that that these these
things like Thou shalt not kill comes
from some guy on above as opposed to
like it makes sense and Society works
better when you don't kill
so that's a morality is a tricky one no
one likes to talk about morality no one
likes to look at it we like to just kind
of do
we like to go along to get along and we
kind of just
go with the morality of contemporary
Society but um yeah I think I think
there's more to be Unearthed there about
you know is that does that work is that
working this is kind of just going along
with the ethics of contemporary Society
is that is that effective morality is
that we look around in the world is is
that working and then just to round out
the uh the these top 10 foundations uh
you have uh increased compassion which
is obviously very very important service
to the poor the heart of almost every
great religion in the world is all about
how you treat the the least of these as
Jesus called them a strong sense of
purpose that's obviously hugely
important but then this is the one that
I I keep coming back to which is and
it's the one that you come back to over
and over again it's how you actually end
the book which is love love love love
is all you need
money can't buy you love love is a mini
splendored thing
yeah you know
he one of the things I dive into is a
device of my own creation which is a
compassion machine
um
what would it be like if we could
Humanity could build a compassion
machine that was so thorough that I
don't know how it works if it's an MRI
or a brain scan or wires on your skull
or whatever it is but by going in this
machine you are able to witness another
person's life someone so different from
you
and you're able to with a totality kind
of be in their shoes and see the world
through their eyes it could be a refugee
kid at the Mexican border it could be a
camel herder in Yemen it could be a a
war victim in the Ukraine that the list
goes on and on a peasant in India and
that you live in their
by seeing the world through their eyes
you're so able to increase your
compassion for that person that it it
threatens to just
you have as much compassion for that
person as you have for yourself and your
own kind of set of circumstances that
are and problems and difficulties and
obstacles that are in front of you worst
episode of Black Mirror ever
[Laughter]
good one
um
and but in so doing
can compassion at that level bring us
through to A New Kind of Love A
different kind of love you know we I
think about love in these concentric
circles like Reza you've got
seven or eight kids and your wife and
you love your kids more than anything
and your wife
and you would do anything for them if
there was an intruder in the house if
there was a sickness or whatever you
would you would sacrifice anything of
yourself for your family I'm gonna put
you on the spot here
your Jessica's family and your family
you would probably do the same thing
um for you know brothers or sisters your
mom whatever it's maybe not quite to the
same extent
and then like your close close friends
you know you you might do that with your
very dearest best friends
and then I think it probably drops off
pretty severely yeah but what what is it
what would it be like to take a Jesus
energy or a Buddha energy to the extreme
where
um Abdullahi faith says uh let your
heart burn with loving kindness for
those who may cross your path let your
heart burn with loving kindness
what would that be like to walk through
the world with our hearts burning with
loving kindness for anyone who crossed
our paths where we would be willing to
sacrifice anything our money our comfort
our time our energy
to care for others who were also
suffering and that's this understanding
of suffering compassion and love can be
the most Mighty force in the universe
and this and I sincerely believe this
you know there might be some people
rolling their eyes right now and like oh
that's hippie dippy stuff
um in its Airy fairy impractical and
yeah blah blah blah they've you know
Jesus said God is love hippies have been
talking about you know love is all you
need for a long time but
but I really think that it can be uh the
most powerful force on planet Earth I
know I said that about prayer but now
I'm saying it about love
well and it is you know the thing that
binds all the great religions together
right I mean if you were to strip
all of these religions down to their
sort of most
core element
it's love it's compassion that's it
that's at the heart of all these things
I love you Reza I love you too I love
you too and I've missed you I've missed
having these conversations I missed you
too this is fun I've uh you know right
so maybe maybe we'll come back to this
again
um but you also looked you you mentioned
it you know a little bit you were
talking about how yeah people get a
little bit like oh come on you know they
roll their eyes or whatever
um yeah that that happened I've been
um guilty of of rolling my eyes
sometimes when people talk about love
um I kept them unrolled throughout that
entire
segment very well done yeah thank you
but also like you know you were talking
about the chapter in The Notorious God
which uh is uh taken from uh the title
of a docu-series that you were trying to
pitch
um uh where you sort of go around and
kind of like you know
look at the ways that people think about
um God and you are a you know Thrice
Emmy nominated uh actor and raconteur
and celebrity and all-around uh lovable
uh guy and no one wanted anything to do
with this show did they they were like
no get the out of this room we do
not want to do a show with the word God
in it no matter who is uh fronting it
like what does that say about
the way that we even think about these
Concepts like religion and spirituality
and God and and the barrier that you
rightly acknowledge is in the way and
the second you start talking about this
kind of stuff and in a serious way
yeah it's um
it was really interesting we put
together a great pitch we had an amazing
Sizzle reel uh a deck describing many
different seasons lots of different
conversations and Journeys one could
have in exploring and examining God and
uh we were deemed the show itself we
were told by Netflix was too
controversial
too controversial is that you weren't
doing anything controversial it's not
like you were uh you know
like a murdering cannibal which is like
40 of Netflix's entertainment now
apparently
um yeah I mean the number one show on
Netflix from the last year was Jeffrey
Dahmer so you can have like serial
killers eating people eating human
brains that's fine that's cool you can
have John Wick killing 873 people in the
course of a movie uh with a bullet to
the brain you can have dating shows with
drunk Housewives hooking up incessantly
but you want to have a conversation
about
what God might be or how science can
help us find God or a reimagination of
God in the modern world searching for
God what we can learn about God the
biggest human question there is and it's
too controversial so you know I'll ask
you what does that say about uh
contemporary Society
I I well you know I mean I got a lot of
things uh ideas about what it says about
the uh entertainment industry
um
but look it it goes back to what you
were saying before and we've we've used
this word god like 40 times in this
conversation and it's so funny this word
which
you know is probably the the single most
used word like the word that I think
people use with the absolute assumption
that everyone knows what you're talking
about and simultaneously it is the word
with the most variable definition like
you get six people and that you will
have six completely different ideas of
what God means and yet they all just
sort of use God as though everybody
knows what they're talking about you
know we've we've talked about this like
this my I've said this before that the
answer to the question do you believe in
God is not yes or no the answer is the
hell do you mean by God
what does that mean even and
I think that that's what it is you know
you you say the word god
and everybody
hears a completely different word right
um and
it's it creates this sort of barrier so
it makes it impossible to talk about the
kind of spirituality that you're talking
about which is specific and crunk
concrete and grounded this isn't just
like you can do yoga sometimes and
you're spiritual you know go on a hike
and you're spiritual I mean that's fine
but that's not what you're that's not
what you're talking about here you're
talking about something very real and
concrete with boundaries and ideas and
and aspirations and goals and and a
foundational myth which I want to get to
uh here in a minute and the second you
start saying the word God in the midst
of all that
people freak out they tune they turn off
you know they they tune out
um they immediately think that you're
talking about what they think God is and
so then they get confused when you say
things like you know when you talk about
Universal ideas they're like yeah but
God hates everybody that's not me and
you know so right right I mean I get it
it's a it's that really tricky word but
it's a word that you just dive head
first into in this book
I go there
um and
someone asked me the other day like but
how do you know there's a God
and I said to them
how do you know
you love your child
how do you know that like
if you had a neuroscientist just say
that this this is a series of chemical
impulses and electrochemical impulses
going on in your brain in order to
propagate the species
how would you respond you'd be like
be like but yet that may be
true but what I feel what I experience
is
uh Beyond The Pale it is
exquisite and and and superlative and
Transcendent beyond all measure and I
feel it in every fiber of my being and
in my heart and in my gut and I'm
transported on a song of love for my
wife for my for my sister or brother for
my child whomever it is
well
that's how one can know God you know
Jesus said God is love and it's that
kind of love that to me is the greatest
parallel to to God and you know I I love
digging into the topic because another
parallel that I use is has to do with uh
one of the episodes we did with my with
my uncle Rhett diesner
um who is a PhD in Beauty studies and
Aesthetics and
uh Beauty itself might be a way to think
about God as opposed to like any kind of
demiurge any kind of like deity of like
a some kind of humanoid figure kind of
like I call them like a Marvel superhero
or a skydaddy up on a cloud like Doling
out favors to those who are blessed and
and Doling out curses to those that are
cursed but Beauty itself love itself are
kind of are Concepts that could be uh
more closely ascribed to what God might
be because
you know and it's one of the things I
love about the Baha'i faith is that
there is a central prayer that we say
each day which is
part of that prayer as you say I was
created to know and worship God and
that's part of the prayer that's one of
the sentences in the in the in the very
short prayer
and how is God described in the Baha'i
faith
as unknowable
um everywhere you turn any page you open
in the high faith God is the unknowable
essence the unknowable essence
so we're created to know
the unknowable
I I love that I love that that dichotomy
I love that mystery that's at the center
of that uh mystical experience
any good religion as people know uh
requires a founding mythology right uh
in the beginning
uh you know there was Darkness and Light
uh you know the the Buddha's Siddhartha
guatama this sort of prince who has
everything in to leave right finally
sees you know want uh of the Prophet
Muhammad you know goes on this
journey into a cave and here's the voice
of God and so you quite smartly decided
Well look if I'm starting my own
religion I need a founding mythology uh
do us a favor would you would you mind
reading us this what you call the new
Legend of the homo sapiens on page 224
uh of your book give us the founding
mythology of this new religion of yours
the new Legend of the homo sapiens when
humans lived in caves and Villages
Community was everything we sought
safety warmth love and family and the
collective we communed with nature
understood it feared it lived in harmony
with it over the years we aimed high and
dreamed big invented world-changing
ideas and Concepts worked together to
eradicate diseases came together to try
and solve problems and fight evil
sadly along the way we also lost sight
of our inherently sacred and spiritual
selves we found ourselves at a
Crossroads Humanity had a choice keep
doing what we've always done or hit
restart
we took up old and revolutionary path of
hopefulness
relying on the idea that the human
spirit is inherently good to build a new
world based on heart-centered wisdom we
left behind our selfish aggressive ways
and came together as one family and the
result Humanity achieved peace and unity
and found dare we say it joy joy
in the end you know that's kind of the
the medication that you're you're uh
prescribing to
um a generation of people not just in
the US not just in the western world but
an entire generation that is
struggling facing a world unlike any I
think that they're the previous
generations have uh witnessed and you
know looking for some sense of meaning
in all this and uh and hell why not why
not just start your own uh religion and
by the way anybody who wants to join
this religion um there isn't really a
formula right there's not like you don't
pray to Jesus you don't say
but you do buy the book
that's step one
becoming a soul Boomer is that right is
that how we would yes if you have either
a copy of the book or a receipt of
purchase uh for the audiobook you are
immediately gained entrance into the
world's fastest growing nascent religion
Soul boom trademark the religion
well listen uh as somebody who spent his
life uh studying the world's religions
uh this one feels pretty good to me it's
not it's a nice one I'm gonna put in my
I'm gonna put it in my top three wait or
we can count on you I'm in
I'm in I love it I already have the book
you you you're in you're in
uh thanks for uh doing another episode
of metaphysical milkshake folks it was
so much fun uh to reunite with Reza uh
to talk about our respective Works what
are you writing these days Reza
I am uh you know as as you know uh my
friend rain uh maybe our audience
doesn't know I uh have retired from
public life so I have yes disabled all
of my social media accounts I am now six
months clean
from social media it's weird very very
weird uh but it's wonderful I I
definitely recommend it to all to all
you out there and uh I'm hanging out at
home and working on some TV stuff
writing some fiction
just loving life out of the spotlight
great great well it's so great seeing
you we've got to think about doing some
more episodes uh metaphysical
milkshakers thank you so much for tuning
in to this very special Soul Boom
episode we hope to see you again soon
Reza thanks for reading my book and for
your thoughtful wise and wonderful
comments as usual well I loved it Soul
boom is now available everywhere is that
can I say that yeah yeah everywhere it's
available everywhere like literally
anywhere you go you can find
Soul boom pick it up except Utah except
Utah pick it up and and join the new
spiritual Revolution thank you Rayne
Wilson for once again shining a light on
these important issues love you man be
well love you too man
[Music]